Hello beautiful nerds. There are a lot of intense actions and discussions going on in the world today, many long overdue, and much of it is happening on social media, for better or worse. The story we have here today is about how Instagram and architecture interact and feed back on each other. It was reported and produced before the COVID lockdown and before the protests over at police brutality have swept the country. So if it feels like it is from another era, it is. But as we witness social media platforms evolving to meet this moment,
大家好，美丽的怪咖们。当今世界正在发生许多激烈的行动和讨论，其中许多早已该发生了，而其中很大一部分都发生在社交媒体上，不论好坏。我们今天要讲的故事是关于Instagram和建筑如何互动并相互影响的。这篇报道是在新冠封锁之前以及席卷全国的警察暴力抗议活动之前采访并制作的。所以，如果它听起来像是来自另一个时代，那确实如此。但当我们见证社交媒体平台不断演变以应对这个时代时，
I think it's worthwhile to report on how they evolved up to now. It's also just a delightful piece, and I think you'll like it. So here it is. This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Instagram has never really been my thing. I just don't tend to use a camera when I'm out in the world. I just like to use my eyeballs,
我认为报道它们迄今为止是如何演变的还是很有价值的。这也只是一篇令人愉悦的文章，我想你们会喜欢的。所以它来了。这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。Instagram从来都不是我的菜。我出门在外面时往往不用相机。我只喜欢用我的眼球，
but I do like scrolling through Instagram occasionally. Mainly because there's a lot of good architecture on there. The app is a wash in pictures of brutalist towers, graffiti walls, and elaborate staircases. And if you're on Instagram, there's a decent chance you've seen a picture of one particular building. It's called the Yard House. The Yard House was designed by a London-based
但我偶尔确实喜欢刷Instagram。主要是因为上面有很多好的建筑。这个应用程序里充斥着粗野主义塔楼、涂鸦墙和精心设计的楼梯的照片。如果你也玩Instagram，你很有可能见过某栋特定建筑的照片。它叫“庭院住宅”（Yard House）。庭院住宅是由一家总部位于伦敦的
architecture collective called a symbol. That's producer and that fits Gerald. A symbol is kind of a big deal. They won the Turner Prize for Visual Art in 2015 for their work reconstructing derelict buildings in Liverpool. But the Yard House was the first building that they ever built.
名为Assemble的建筑集体设计的。那是制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。Assemble挺了不起的。他们因在利物浦重建废弃建筑的工作而荣获2015年透纳视觉艺术奖。但“庭院住宅”是他们建造的第一座建筑。
The designers had just moved into this new studio and stratford near where the 2012 Olympics were being held. It was on this street called Sugar House Lane and they wanted to build something on the empty yard out front, a collaborative workshop for designers and artists. There was the idea that this yard house could be a new model of affordable workspace. This is Joe Halligan, one of the architects in assemble. So the artist no longer have to live or work in cold warehouse spaces on the fringes, but they can be in these new warm insulated buildings.
这些设计师刚刚搬进他们在斯特拉特福德的新工作室，这里靠近2012年奥运会的举办地。它位于一条叫“糖屋巷”（Sugar House Lane）的街道上，他们想在正门前的空地上建造一些东西，一个供设计师和艺术家使用的合作工作室。当时的想法是，这个庭院住宅可以成为经济型工作空间的新模式。这是乔·哈利根（Joe Halligan），Assemble的一位建筑师。因此，艺术家们不必再住在边缘地区寒冷的仓库空间里，而是可以住在这些新建的温暖隔热的建筑里。
The problem was that they only had a short term lease. The property, like a lot of properties in Stratford, was going to be redeveloped after the Olympics. And so they knew that they needed to build a cheap structure that could be easily disassembled. So knowing that we only had the lease for two years or something, it was like, how can you build a building as kind of affordably and efficiently as possible?
问题在于他们的租期很短。这处房产就像斯特拉特福德的许多房产一样，将在奥运会后重新开发。因此他们知道，他们需要建造一个可以轻松拆卸的廉价结构。所以既然知道我们只有两三年的租金，我们就会想：如何以尽可能经济高效的方式建造一座建筑呢？
The designers focused on things that made the building functional and inexpensive. They used a simple timber frame structure and cheap mass produced components. Everything's bolted and screwed so that you can take it down again. The building was like an urban barn with high ceilings and lots of open workspace. But the reason you may have seen this building has nothing to do with any of that. The Yard House is an Instagram famous for its DIY design or it's off the shelf affordability. Now, it's famous for one design decision
设计师们专注于使建筑具有功能性且成本低廉的元素。他们使用了简单的木框架结构和廉价的大批量生产组件。所有东西都是用螺栓和螺丝固定，以便你可以再次将其拆卸。这座建筑就像一个城市里的谷仓，有高高的天花板和许多开放式的工作空间。但你可能见过这座建筑的原因与所有这些都没有关系。庭院住宅之所以在Instagram上出名，并不是因为它的DIY设计或现成的实惠价格。现在，它是因一个设计决定而闻名，
that a very little to do with Assembles larger vision. The architects knew that they were gonna have to look at this very functional building all day long. And so they allowed themselves with seemed at the time like one small concession to beauty. functional building all day long. And so they allowed themselves with seemed at the time, like one small concession to beauty. So on the one facade that faced the yard, we knew we wanted to do something special
这个决定与Assemble的宏大愿景几乎没有什么关系。建筑师们知道他们得整天面对这座非常功能性的建筑。因此，他们允许自己在当时看来是对美的唯一一次小小的让步。整天面对这座非常功能性的建筑。因此，他们允许自己在当时看来是对美的唯一一次小小的让步。所以在那面面向庭院的立面上，我们知道我们想做一些特别的事情，
that would kind of elevate it in some way. One special wall. I guess it's a bit like an Italian church or something, you know, where the front facade is marble and it's got this kind of incredible market tree, but then the back is really just like bricks slapped together. They wanted to make their facade themselves, and so when they found a book on traditional hand-made shingle work lying around the office, they took it as a sign. They started pouring cement shingles in the studio and mixing each batch with a different colored pigment.
某种程度上能提升它的格调。一面特别的墙。我想这有点像意大利的教堂什么的，你知道，它的正面是马赛克大理石，有这种令人难以置信的镶嵌细工，但背面其实就像是把砖头胡乱拼凑在一起。他们想自己制作立面，所以当他们在办公室里翻到一本关于传统手工木瓦制作的书时，他们把它当成了一个征兆。他们开始在工作室里浇筑水泥木瓦，并在每批产品中混合不同颜色的颜料。
And after making thousands of these tiles, they ended up with this gradient of different colors. So together when you see them on the facade, it becomes a bit like a lizard's skin or something, but pastel. So quite surreal. To me, it looks like the side of like a whimsicle tropical fish.
在制作了数千块这样的瓦片之后，他们最终得到了这种不同颜色的渐变效果。所以当你在立面上看到它们时，它有点像蜥蜴的皮肤什么的，但却是粉彩的。非常超现实。在我看来，它看起来像是一条异想天开的热带鱼的侧面。
Yeah, yeah, fish scales, but definitely a tropical fish. It's not something you would find in the channel, something round Britain. It's definitely like Bahamas or something, I think. A beautiful tropical fish of a building. Tucked away in a post-industrial hinterland, right next to a highway. Which isn't that friendly to kind of pedestrian, particularly tourists. But if Joe thought that tourists weren't going to find this hidden pastel wonder wall, he thought wrong.
对，对，鱼鳞，但绝对是一条热带鱼。这不是你在运河里能找到的东西，不是英国周边的东西。这绝对像是巴哈马群岛那边的风格，我想。一座长得像美丽热带鱼的建筑。它隐藏在一个后工业时代的腹地，紧邻一条高速公路。这条路对行人，尤其是游客来说并不那么友好。但如果乔以为游客不会发现这堵隐藏的粉彩奇迹之墙，那他就想错了。
You know, in the summertime we would eat our lunch outside, and what we started to notice would be groups of people kind of wandering in and then getting their photograph taken in front of the building. In front of the wall really. Soon photos of the wall started circulating on Instagram with the hashtag Sugar House Studios and a geotag of the exact location of the assemble offices. Which only drove more people to the wall. It was quite frequent. It's maybe like 20 people every day would turn up.
你知道，在夏天，我们会去外面吃午饭，我们开始注意到的是，一群群的人会漫步进来，然后站在建筑前面拍照。准确地说，是在那面墙前面。很快，这堵墙的照片开始在Instagram上流传，带有#糖屋工作室（Sugar House Studios）的标签，并带有Assemble办公室确切位置的地理标记。这只会吸引更多人来到这堵墙前。这相当频繁。大约每天有20人会现身。
You kind of, they just become part of the furniture of what it is to work, It was quite frequent. It's maybe like 20 people every day would turn up. You kind of, they just become part of the furniture of what it is to work there. But really people were not interested in the work that we were doing. They weren't interested in affordable workspace for artists, or the fact that assemble had managed to build something so cheap and yet functional. They were only interested in that beautiful facade. Professional photo crews started calling the office to try and book the wall.
你有点，他们只是成为了你在那里工作的一部分，这相当频繁。大约每天有20人会现身。你有点，他们只是成为了你在那里工作的一部分。但实际上人们对我们所做的工作并不感兴趣。他们对艺术家的经济型工作空间不感兴趣，也不关心Assemble设法建造了如此便宜却又实用的东西。他们只对那面美丽的立面感兴趣。专业的摄影团队开始打电话到办公室试图预订这堵墙。
And people were showing up from all over the world. But definitely, like lots and lots of international guests. Here is an international community. Pffft. An international community of people coming together to take more or less the same photo over and over again. It's quite entertaining to watch them. People would always do this jump in the air so it kind of looks like they're floating within space against this backdrop.
来自世界各地的人们纷纷出现。但绝对有很多很多的国际访客。这是一个国际社群。噗。一个国际社群的人们聚集在一起，一遍又一遍地拍着大同小异的照片。看着他们挺好玩的。人们总是在空中跳跃，这样在这个背景下，他们看起来就像是在太空中漂浮一样。
People would take photos of couples kissing and babies crawling and kids doing handstands in front of the wall. Someone pulled their pug and they placed their kind of pug there and take photos of their pug in front of the wall. Someone pulled the pug and they placed their kind of pug there and take photos of their pug in front of this wall. What was happening with Assembles Mall was an extreme version of a pretty common phenomenon. People take a photo of something cool out in the world, like a waterfall or a piece of graffiti or sculpture. And other people see that photo and they say,
人们会拍摄情侣接吻、婴儿爬行以及孩子们在墙前倒立的照片。有人拉着他们的哈巴狗，把他们的哈巴狗放在那里，在墙前给哈巴狗拍照。有人拉着哈巴狗，把他们的哈巴狗放在那里，在这堵墙前给哈巴狗拍照。Assemble的这面墙上发生的事情，其实是一个相当普遍现象的极端版本。人们在世界上拍下某个酷炫东西的照片，比如瀑布、一幅涂鸦或雕塑。然后其他人看到那张照片就会说：
hey, I want my own version of that picture. I take photos, you know, it's like, if I went to the pyramids, I'd definitely take a photo. I'm not comparing our walks to the pyramids. Did you ever get an answer on kind of like how it went viral? Like was there an instigating event, or was it just the slow accretion of likes? I don't know, I can't pinpoint one particular blog or like this influencer took a photo of it or something.
嘿，我也想要一张那样照片的同款。我拍照嘛，你知道，就像我去金字塔也一定会拍照一样。我并不是把我们的作品与金字塔进行比较。你有没有得到过关于它是如何走红的答案？比如是有什么导火索事件，还是仅仅是点赞的慢慢积累？我不知道，我无法指出某一个特定的博客，或者某个网红拍了张照片之类的。
Maybe it was the pug. Maybe it was the pug. Yeah, maybe it was the pug. Maybe it was the pug. The architects in assemble weren't trying to lure people to the backlands of East London, but they accidentally designed the perfect Instagram flytrap, a wall that met all the criteria of what stands out on the app. Because Instagram is creating new rules about what kind of design looks good and what deserves our attention. Visuals that look good on Instagram are actually very simple.
也许是那只哈巴狗。也许是那只哈巴狗。对，也许是那只哈巴狗。也许是那只哈巴狗。Assemble的建筑师们并不是想把人们吸引到伦敦东部的偏远落后地区，但他们不小心设计出了完美的Instagram捕蝇草——一堵满足了该应用程序上脱颖而出的所有标准的墙。因为Instagram正在为什么样的设计好看、什么值得我们关注创造新的规则。在Instagram上看起来不错的视觉效果其实非常简单。
This is Alexandra Lang, architecture critic for Curved and Longtime Friend of the Show, and she says that for an image to look good on a tiny screen in the palm of your hand, it has to have certain characteristics. Bold colors and patterns are good. It can just be, you know, a colored wall or a patterned wall. Not too many fiddly details. It has to be like relatively few elements centering is good. A pop of color is good.
这是亚历山德拉·朗（Alexandra Lang），《Curved》杂志的建筑评论员，也是本节目的老朋友。她说，为了让图像在手掌中的小屏幕上看起来不错，它必须具备某些特征。鲜艳的色彩和图案很好。它可以只是，你知道的，一面彩色的墙或带图案的墙。不要有太多繁琐的细节。它必须有相对较少的元素，居中很好。一抹亮色很好。
And the lighting has to be good enough so that the color stand out. And in general, flatter is better. The thing is a good Instagram photo is really a pretty shallow photo. So walls and floors and pretty simple geometric patterns really look best on Instagram. Like if you go through the feed and see kind of what pops, it's this kind of flat patterning. Alexander Lang is particularly interested in patterned floors. I feel like the first cool floor that I noticed getting Instagram'd all the time was the blue and white tile floor
而且光线必须足够好，才能让颜色脱颖而出。总的来说，画面越平坦越好。问题是，一张好的Instagram照片其实是一张相当浅薄的照片。因此，墙壁、地板和相当简单的几何图案在Instagram上看起来效果确实最好。就像如果你浏览动态并看看有什么地方比较抓人眼球，就会发现这种扁平的图案。亚历山德拉·朗对有图案的地板特别感兴趣。我觉得我注意到的第一个在Instagram上经常被刷屏的酷炫地板是那个蓝白相间的瓷砖地板，
in the Intelligencia coffee and silver lake, which is by best or architecture. This hip LA coffee shop had these amazing geometric tiles. They ran all the way across the floor and then up the front of the coffee bar and kind of over the lip. So it was basically almost like a carpet of tiles. A carpet of tiles that made the perfect background for an Instagram picture of a customer's desert
位于银湖区的Intelligentsia咖啡馆，由Bestor Architecture设计。这家时髦的洛杉矶咖啡馆拥有这些令人惊叹的几何瓷砖。它们一直延伸到整个地板，然后延伸到咖啡吧的前面，并越过边缘。所以它基本上就像是一块瓷砖地毯。一块瓷砖地毯，为顾客的沙漠靴在Instagram上的照片提供了完美的背景。
boots. And then suddenly it was like every new coffee bar had patterned tile. Just like assemble, the intelligentsia floor designer didn't set out to make something for Instagram. But in recent years designers have begun to intentionally design spaces that will look good on the app. Lang says that hotel and restaurant interiors, in particular, have been designed to lure customers with their Instagram ability. One architect told me that it's really important to have an Instagramable bathroom. So, like, good lighting, a cool feature wall behind the mirror. People want to pop into the bathroom and take their selfie and sort of say, like, I was here.
然后突然之间，就像每家新开的咖啡馆都有带图案的瓷砖一样。就像Assemble一样，Intelligentsia的地板设计师并不是为了Instagram而设计东西的。但近年来，设计师们开始刻意设计在应用程序上看起来不错的空间。朗说，尤其是酒店和餐厅的室内设计，旨在用它们的“出片率”来吸引顾客。一位建筑师告诉我，拥有一个适合拍照发Instagram的浴室非常重要。所以，比如要有好的光线，镜子后面有一面很酷的特色墙。人们想冲进浴室拍自拍，然后说：我来过这里。
These days, clients often ask designers to create Instagram moments, which basically means some feature in the space that is just there so that people can take a photo with it. Every time we're asked to do it, we're like, oh, not another Instagram wall or whatever. Verna Alexander is the co-founder of O plus A, an interior design firm in San Francisco that primarily works on office spaces for tech companies. And she says that even when clients aren't demanding a designated selfie spot, platforms like Instagram are still impacting how designers do their work. So we know that when we photograph projects, we need to have that first image, that first shot
如今，客户经常要求设计师创造“Instagram时刻”，这基本上意味着空间中的某个功能，它的存在就是为了让人们可以与之合影。每次我们被要求这样做时，我们都会想：哦，又来一面Instagram墙之类的。韦尔达·亚历山德拉（Verda Alexander）是旧金山室内设计公司O plus A的联合创始人，该公司主要为科技公司设计办公空间。她说，即使客户没有要求指定的自拍照打卡点，像Instagram这样的平台仍然在影响着设计师的工作方式。所以我们知道，当我们拍摄项目时，我们需要有那第一张图像，那第一张照片，
that is going to draw people in, that's going to get people excited, that's going to want people to pin it or look at it twice, right? And so, whether we do it consciously or subconsciously, we're always designing for that Instagram moment. An Instagram isn't the only app that's impacted the architecture and design world. Verda Alexander was a judge this past year at a few design competitions, and she says
能够吸引人们，让人兴奋，让人想要收藏它或看两眼，对吧？所以，无论我们是有意识还是无意识地这样做，我们总是在为那个Instagram时刻进行设计。Instagram并不是唯一一个对建筑和设计界产生影响的应用程序。韦尔达·亚历山德拉去年在几个设计竞赛中担任评委，她说
it felt like everyone was just copying what was cool on Pinterest. Which of the time was this very particular style of Italian postmodern design associated with a 1980s architecture firm called the Memphis Group. So I would be looking at these projects. It all had pastel pink or round mirrors or narrow arched doorways. Like they were all the same details. She says that when designers rely too heavily on platforms like Pinterest for inspiration,
感觉每个人都在抄袭Pinterest上最酷的东西。当时Pinterest上非常流行这种特殊的意大利后现代主义设计风格，它与20世纪80年代一个名为“孟菲斯集团”（Memphis Group）的建筑事务所联系在一起。所以我在看这些项目时。它们全都有粉红色、圆形的镜子或狭窄的拱形门道。就像它们的细节全都一样。她说，当设计师过度依赖Pinterest等平台来获取灵感时，
they can get stuck in this derivative loop. Snake eating its tail, right? They stay within this circle and don't expand beyond. That, I guess that's my fear. That by focusing on digital trends, designers lose track of livability, workability, climate, all things that you can't really capture in a photograph. Joe Halligan from Assemble says that as a designer, it's impossible not to think
他们就会陷入这种衍生的循环中。蛇咬自己的尾巴，对吧？他们留在这个圈子里，没有向外拓展。我想这就是我的担忧。通过关注数字潮流，设计师们失去了对宜居性、实用性、气候的关注——所有这些你在照片中无法真正捕捉到的东西。来自Assemble的乔·哈利根说，作为一名设计师，不可能不去思考
about how something you make will be photographed later on. I think you have to be aware slightly of that, that when you finish this building that you spent five years on, the way most people will view it will be through the image. Which raises tough questions. Do you then pander to that or do you still ensure that the kind of main focus is on the person who visits the building and experiences it? It's not hard to imagine what the world would look like if everyone just went full
你制作的东西日后将如何被拍照。我认为你必须要稍微意识到这一点，当你完成了你花了五年时间建造的这座建筑时，大多数人看到它的方式将是通过图片。这就提出了一个难题。你是去迎合这一点，还是仍然确保主要的访问者是那些参观这座建筑并亲身体验它的人？不难想象，如果每个人都全力
on with Instagram pandering. In some ways that world already exists. Just look at so-called Instagram playgrounds. Which are essentially stage sets made for taking the greatest concentration of amazing selfies in the shortest amount of time. The Museum of Ice Cream and the Color Factory aren't really museums or factories. Their spaces filled with colorful rooms
去迎合Instagram，世界会变成什么样。在某种程度上，那个世界已经存在了。看看所谓的Instagram游乐场就知道了。它们本质上是为在最短时间内拍摄最多、最棒的自拍照而搭建的舞台布景。冰淇淋博物馆和色彩工厂并不是真正的博物馆或工厂。它们的空间里充满了色彩缤纷的房间、
and sculptures and ball pits, all of which are designed for the sole purpose of being the backdrop of an iPhone picture. Then I've written about those as kind of like the least fun playgrounds for grownups that you could possibly make. You aren't really supposed to play in them at all. Just take a few pictures and move on to the next room. Yeah, it reduces architecture to a photo op. It turns architecture into basically a flat experience. Right now this flat photo op architecture feels pretty contained to the cafes and boutique hotels
雕塑和海洋球池，所有这些设计的唯一目的就是成为iPhone照片的背景。然后我曾写过文章，称这些是你能想象到的对成年人最不好玩的游乐场。你根本不应该在里面玩。只需拍几张照片，然后移步下一个房间。是的，它将建筑贬低成了一个拍照的布景。它基本上把建筑变成了一种扁平的体验。目前，这种扁平的拍照背景式建筑似乎主要局限于咖啡馆、精品酒店
and the Instagram playgrounds, although it is not hard to imagine it escaping from the color factory and slipping out into the broader city. On the other hand, maybe our collective Instagram moment won't last all that long. The kids these days are on TikTok or using Instagram more for its story function.
和Instagram游乐场，尽管不难想象它会逃离色彩工厂并溜进更广阔的城市。另一方面，也许我们集体的Instagram时刻不会持续那么久。现在的孩子们都在用TikTok，或者更多地将Instagram用于其快拍功能。
And we're seeing less of those carefully composed selfies against the perfect backdrop and more short videos with a lot of jump cuts. Get ready for TikTok architecture. Which actually sounds pretty delightful. Yeah, I honestly don't even know what that would look like. But regardless of what happens next, Alexander Lang doesn't want us to get carried away with this narrative that Instagram has been bad for design.
我们看到那些以完美背景精心构图的自拍照越来越少，而带有大量跳切的短视频越来越多。准备迎接TikTok建筑学吧。这听起来其实挺愉快的。是的，老实说，我甚至不知道那会是什么样子。但无论接下来发生什么，亚历山德拉·朗都不希望我们被这样一种叙事冲昏头脑：即Instagram对设计有害。
I feel like people keep trying to goad me into saying, like Instagram is ruining architecture. I would never do that. Okay, maybe I did that. And I just, I don't want to say that because I can still feel that joy that I felt that day in Melbourne. Lang was in Melbourne, Australia, about 10 years ago,
我觉得人们总是试图怂恿我说，Instagram正在毁掉建筑。我绝不会那样做。好吧，也许我那样做过。我只是，我不想那样说，因为我仍然能感受到那天在墨尔本感受到的那种快乐。朗大约10年前在澳大利亚墨尔本，
when Instagram was just getting going. And it turns out that Melbourne is an underappreciated mecca for bizarre post-modern architecture. And I'm just completely wowed by these buildings because they're spiky, they're covered in neon, they're just, they're really kind of crazy. And they're like nothing I've ever seen before. And I suddenly have this overwhelming desire to share.
当时Instagram才刚刚起步。事实证明，墨尔本是一个被低估的奇异后现代主义建筑麦加。我完全被这些建筑惊艳到了，因为它们带有尖顶，上面覆盖着霓虹灯，它们真的很疯狂。它们就像我以前从未见过的东西一样。我突然有了一种强烈的分享欲。
And so she posted picture after picture on Twitter until someone was like, Alexandra, this is very terrible. Twitter etiquette, like take it to Instagram. Lang had an Instagram account that she barely used and so she started using it and posting all these pictures of buildings. The Australians were like, yeah, yeah, yeah, we know.
于是她在推特上一张接一张地发布照片，直到有人说：亚历山德拉，这非常违反推特礼仪，去Instagram上发吧。朗有一个她几乎不怎么用的Instagram账号，于是她开始使用它，并发布所有这些建筑的照片。澳大利亚人则表示：行行行，我们知道了。
And I also was like, wow, we don't know what this is. What is this magical place, Melbourne? Exactly. And so I just realized that there was a super direct way for me to share my architectural experience, which is mostly joy because I just love looking at new buildings. And Instagram was the perfect platform for that. my architectural experience, which is mostly joy because I just love looking at new buildings. And Instagram was the perfect platform for that. And it turns out a lot of people love joyful pictures of buildings. My son, who's 12, told me the only time he ever mentions me is when he wants to flex to his friends and his mother has 42,000 Instagram followers.
我也觉得，哇，我们不知道这是什么。墨尔本这个神奇的地方是什么？没错。所以我意识到，有一个超级直接的方法可以让我分享我的建筑体验，这主要是快乐，因为我就是喜欢看新建筑。而Instagram是实现这一目标的完美平台。我的建筑体验，这主要是快乐，因为我就是喜欢看新建筑。而Instagram是实现这一目标的完美平台。事实证明，很多人都喜欢关于建筑的快乐照片。我12岁的儿子告诉我，他唯一一次提到我，是当他想向朋友炫耀他母亲在Instagram上有42,000名粉丝的时候。
Alexander Lang's time using Instagram, let her to believe that the app can have a positive effect on architecture. Sure, you might get a few too many selfie walls, but the app can offer a window into the built world and encourage people to notice overlooked buildings. I feel like for a long time, architecture was really associated with specific capital cities. And so most people were only seeing a really limited slice of architecture. And I think something that I do and a lot of other people do is show that kind of architecture is everywhere. And even on the design end, Alexandra Lang doesn't necessarily think that Instagram moments
亚历山德拉·朗使用Instagram的经历让她相信，该应用程序可以对建筑产生积极的影响。当然，你可能会看到稍微多了一点的自拍墙，但这个应用程序可以提供一扇了解建筑世界的窗户，并鼓励人们注意到那些被忽视的建筑。我觉得很长一段时间以来，建筑真的只与特定的首都城市联系在一起。所以大多数人看到的建筑其实非常有限。我认为我正在做的事情以及许多其他人正在做的事情，就是展示这种建筑无处不在。甚至在设计方面，亚历山德拉·朗也不认为Instagram时刻
get in the way of good architecture. The truth is you can simultaneously, you know, design a good building and make sure that it has a good Instagram moment in it. And those things are not mutually exclusive and they don't, like, one doesn't undermine the other. But there's another reason why it probably isn't accurate to say that Instagram is ruining architecture because Designing for the camera is really nothing new certainly in the 20th century from the 1920s and 30s onward any ambitious architect has been conscious of and very attentive to the role of photography in conveying his or her work to a broader public. This is architectural historian Keith Agner from the University of Oregon.
会妨碍好建筑的发展。事实是，你可以同时设计出一座好建筑，并确保其中包含一个适合发Instagram的绝佳时刻。这两件事并不相互排斥，一个也不会损害另一个。但还有另一个原因，为什么说Instagram正在毁掉建筑可能并不准确，因为为相机进行设计并不是什么新鲜事。当然在20世纪，从20世纪20年代和30年代开始，任何有抱负的建筑师都一直意识到并非常关注摄影在向更广泛公众传达他或她的作品方面的作用。这是来自俄勒冈大学的建筑历史学家基思·埃格纳（Keith Egnor）。
Architects like Neutro, like Liquid Bucie, like Luis Baragon in Mexico, begin to use photography to convey certain things about their architecture that they wanted the larger public to see. Luis Baragon worked closely with one photographer in particular, a man named Armando Salas Portugal. You know, I would go so far as to say there are very few major architects.
像纽特拉（Neutra）、勒·柯布西耶（Le Corbusier）、墨西哥的路易斯·巴拉甘（Luis Barragán）这样的建筑师开始利用摄影来传达他们建筑的某些特色，以便让大众看到。路易斯·巴拉甘与一位特定的摄影师密切合作，这个人叫阿曼多·萨拉斯·葡萄牙（Armando Salas Portugal）。你知道，我甚至可以说，几乎没有哪个重要建筑师……
In fact, I can't really even think of another major architect whose reputation is so tightly bound up with the photographs of a single photographer. The most famous photos of Baragon's work are really a collaboration between two visual artists. Egnor doesn't think that Baragon designed his buildings for the photographs, but he was an architect who was supremely interested in the way things looked, not just in fully-dimensional, lived experience, but also on a two-dimensional photographic surface. When Beragon won the Pritzker Prize for Architecture in 1980, he wasn't very well-known outside of
事实上，我甚至想不出另一个重要建筑师，其声誉与单一摄影师的照片如此紧密地捆绑在一起。关于巴拉甘作品的最著名的照片实际上是两位视觉艺术家合作的产物。埃格纳不认为巴拉甘是为了拍照而设计他的建筑的，但他是一位极其关注事物外观的建筑师，不仅关注三维的全方位生活体验，还关注二维的摄影表面。当巴拉甘于1980年荣获普利兹克建筑奖时，他在
Mexico, and many of his best buildings had fallen into this repair. But there were still beautiful photographs of them. Keith Higner actually wrote to the members of the Pritzker jury to ask how they had picked Baragon. And most people politely wrote back and said, well, we can't really talk about those deliberations. But one member of the jury did write back and said, well, in fact, most of us had never actually seen any of Baragonons' buildings, except in photographs. Not surprisingly, Louise Barragons' buildings are now really popular on Instagram. In fact, Casa Barragon in Mexico City charges extra if you want to take photos on your tour,
墨西哥以外并不是很知名，他的许多最好的建筑都已年久失修。但仍然有它们美丽的相片。基思·埃格纳实际上写信给普利兹克评委会成员，询问他们是如何选中巴拉甘的。大多数人礼貌地回信说，嗯，我们真的不能谈论那些审议过程。但评委会的一位成员回信说，事实上，我们大多数人实际上从未见过巴拉甘的任何建筑，除了在照片中。毫无疑问，路易斯·巴拉甘的建筑现在在Instagram上非常受欢迎。事实上，墨西哥城的巴拉甘故居（Casa Barragán）如果你想在参观时拍照，会收取额外费用，
and people gladly pay the fee to get onto the roof. Which has the really famous pink walls that people tend to want to photograph themselves with. The truth is that most people aren't taking Alexandra Lang style pictures that make you think about Paragon's architecture in new ways. They want a selfie against one of those beautiful bright pink walls that really make a perfect selfie background, it's understandable. And those selfies are consumed by thousands of people on an app, who may or may not have any idea about the real world context.
人们为了能登上屋顶，很乐意支付这笔费用。这里有非常著名的粉红色墙壁，人们往往想以它为背景拍照。事实是，大多数人并没有拍摄亚历山德拉·朗那种能让你以全新方式思考巴拉甘建筑的照片。他们只是想在那些美丽的亮粉色墙壁前拍一张自拍，这确实构成了完美的自拍照背景，这是可以理解的。这些自拍照被应用程序上的数千人消费，他们可能知道也可能不知道现实世界的背景。
That picture of your friend in front of a pink wall could be at the Baragon House in Mexico City, or it could be in front of the bright pink wall at the Palsmiss store in Los Angeles. You can get almost the same photo, and you know, Palsmiss has said he was thinking of Baragon pink when he painted that wall. People aren't always posting a photo on Instagram because they're interested in telling the
你朋友站在粉红色墙前的照片可能是在墨西哥城的巴拉甘故居，也可能是在洛杉矶保罗·史密斯（Paul Smith）商店的亮粉色墙前。你可以拍到几乎相同的照片，而且你知道的，保罗·史密斯在粉刷那堵墙时曾说过他想到了巴拉甘粉红。人们在Instagram上发照片并不总是因为他们有兴趣告诉
world about some cool building. Sometimes they're just using some building as a tool to create a cool image. It doesn't necessarily even matter which building they use to do it. And as the number of images grows, they start to lose their connection with the physical world. Just look at what happened to the assemble wall. As more and more people came to the offices, thousands of images of their colorful wall
世界关于某个酷炫建筑的事。有时他们只是把某个建筑当作创造酷炫图像的工具。甚至不一定非要用哪个建筑来做到这一点。随着图像数量的增加，它们开始失去与物理世界的联系。看看Assemble的那堵墙发生了什么就知道了。随着越来越多的人来到办公室，数千张他们彩色墙壁的图像
started to circulate online. And then the architects started noticing the cement tiles appearing as a stock photo, like a generic wallpaper you might use for your desktop or a zoom background. So, well, you can't see the building itself, but you just see a crop of these kind of colorful tiles. And then they noticed that stock photo was actually being printed onto stuff,
开始在网上流传。然后建筑师们开始注意到水泥瓦作为素材图片出现，就像你可能用于桌面或Zoom背景的通用壁纸一样。所以，虽然你看不到建筑本身，但你只能看到这些彩色瓷砖的一部分。然后他们注意到这张素材图片实际上被印在了各种东西上，
laptop cases, and rugs, and picture frames. So I remember being in Copenhagen and seeing someone sitting on the bus there with a phone cover with this building that, you know, we'd built in East London and they have no idea, well, I don't think they would have any idea of the context of where that image has come from. And that's super weird, I think. That's like super weird. And then to make matters weirder, the wall that became a photo became a wall again.
比如笔记本电脑包、地毯和相框。所以我还记得在哥本哈根看到有人坐在那里的公交车上，手机壳上印着我们建在伦敦东部的这座建筑，他们根本不知道，嗯，我想他们绝不会知道那个图像背景的来源。我觉得这超级奇怪。这简直超级奇怪。然后更奇怪的是，那堵变成照片的墙，又重新变成了一堵墙。
So what we saw then was a request from a, I think it was in a shopping mall in China, and it was the quest to kind of rebuild a part of the wall so that people within this shopping mall could get their photograph taken against this kind of image. So it's almost like they've seen the stock photo and they want to get their photo taken against the stock photo. Wait, so did they build it? Yeah, they built it. Yeah, it was built. And I think if you look on Instagram, you can then see photos of people against that pool. I've seen these photos, and it's just so strange to imagine this journey from architecture to image, to architecture to image. As for the real wall, the yardhouse eventually had to come down when the lease ran out. But it had always been the plan.
所以我们看到的是来自一个地方的请求，我想是在中国的一个购物中心，要求重建部分墙壁，这样这个购物中心的人们就可以在这种图像前拍照。所以这几乎就像是他们看到了素材照片，然后想要在素材照片前拍照一样。等等，所以他们真的建了？对，他们建了。对，建成了。我想如果你在Instagram上查看，你就能看到人们在那堵墙前的照片。我看过这些照片，从建筑到图像，再从图像到建筑再到图像，想象这段旅程真是太奇怪了。至于真正的墙，租约到期后，庭院住宅最终不得不拆除。但这原本就是计划的一部分。
They unscrewed the screws, unbolted the bolts, and packed up their building. Assemble, solve the structure. The your house is currently sitting in pieces in storage somewhere in London. So it still exists, but just in just in parts. I asked Joe who they sold it to, but he said it was a secret. I don't think I could tell him anyway. I don't think I can say that.
他们拧下螺丝，拆掉螺栓，打包了他们的建筑。Assemble把建筑结构卖了。庭院住宅目前正零零碎碎地存放在伦敦的某个仓库里。所以它依然存在，只是变成了零件。我问乔他们卖给谁了，但他说是秘密。我想我无论如何也不能告诉他。我想我不能说。
Yeah. We didn't sell it to Instagram. We didn't sell it to Instagram, We didn't sell it to Instagram. We should have made that offer, I think. Today, Joe and the rest of his colleagues work out of a new office in South London. Although they kept their name, sugar house studios. Which may have been a mistake,
对。我们没有把它卖给Instagram。我们没有把它卖给Instagram，我们没有把它卖给Instagram。我想我们当时应该开出这个报价的。今天，乔和他的其余同事在伦敦南部的一个新办公室工作。尽管他们保留了原来的名字——糖屋工作室。这可能是一个错误，
because to this day, people continue to show up unannounced. And it's really, you know, it's quite sad in a way. When someone comes all the way and then they ring the doorbell and they say, like, I'm outside, there's three of us. And, you know, I'm in a wedding dress. And like, we've got our photographer here. It's like, we just want to know where the wall is. And you have to say, oh, unfortunately,
因为直到今天，人们仍然不请自来地出现。这真的，你知道，从某种程度上说挺让人难过的。当有人大老远跑来按门铃说，我在外面，我们有三个人。然后你知道的，我穿着婚纱。而且就像，我们的摄影师也在这里。这就像是，我们只想知道墙在哪里。然后你不得不说，哦，不幸的是，
like, we took that down two years ago. As for the old Locke and East London, it looks very different now. Stratford was completely transformed by the Olympics. It's a fancy neighborhood now with boutiques and wine bars. But the old photos are still tagged to the old location. So if you ever see someone wandering around Stratford carrying a pug and looking confused at their phone, don't worry. They're probably just chasing a ghost geotag on the hunt for the most The wall that became a photo, that became a wall, that became a photo, became a blanket. That story.
就像，我们在两年前就把那个拆了。至于伦敦东部的老锁（Lock），现在的样子大不相同了。斯特拉特福德因奥运会而彻底改变。现在它是一个拥有精品店和红酒吧的高档社区。但老照片仍然带有老地方的地理标记。所以如果你看到有人在斯特拉特福德闲逛，手里抱着一只哈巴狗，看着手机一脸茫然，别担心。他们可能只是在追逐一个幽灵般的地理标签，寻找最绝的那个……那堵变成照片的墙，又变成了一堵墙，变成了一张照片，最后变成了一条毛毯。就是那个故事。
After this. Okay, so I'm in this video with Emmett Fitzgerald, who reported that story. How you doing? Good. Good. Good. So we, this is where we often have these like little tangents and the story that don't always make it into the story and the code is a good place to do them. So what do you have for us? You know, a funny thing I think about this story for me in general is that this is such a side story for assemble. There's really kind of impressive and cool group of architects, and as I was reading more about them and learning about them, I could have done a bunch of stories about them.
广告之后见。好的，所以我现在和报道那个故事的埃米特·菲茨杰拉德在一起。你好吗？很好。很好。很好。所以我们，这就是我们经常在故事中加入这些小插曲的地方，这些小插曲并不总是能进入正式的故事中，而代码（指后期制作环节）是一个放置它们的好地方。那么你给我们带来了什么？你知道，我觉得这个故事对我来说一个有趣的地方在于，对于Assemble来说，这只是一个微不足道的副业。他们真的是那种非常令人印象深刻且酷炫的建筑师团队，当我阅读更多关于他们的信息并了解他们时，我本可以围绕他们做一堆故事。
And this felt a funny disservice to them as an organization to do this thing about Instagram. But, you know, but it also is funny, I think, for them that, you know, no matter how many cool projects they do, it's like, it's hard to imagine that they're ever going to design something that gets seen by more people and appreciated in a lot of ways, by more people, at least photographically. Right. Then that wall. And I think that for the most part, Joe Halligan is okay with that. I wonder how many people know it's a building though, or what the building is. I guess that's what's a bit funny about it, isn't it?
作为一个组织，仅仅为了这个Instagram的事情而报道他们，感觉对他们来说有点不公平。但你知道，但对他们来说这也很有趣，不管他们做了多少酷炫的项目，很难想象他们会设计出什么东西，能够被更多的人看到并在很多方面受到赞赏，至少在摄影层面上是这样。没错。比那堵墙还要多。我想乔·哈利根大体上对此是可以接受的。不过我不知道有多少人知道那是一栋建筑，或者那栋建筑是什么。我想这才是有点滑稽的地方，对吧？
It normally gets described as a wall, and I don't think people know that it's like affordable workspace, which is a kind of pilot project for what could happen of the legacy of the Olympics. It could be deployed to allow artists to continue to work in the city. I think it's kind of a shame that all of that stuff gets lost. It just becomes this kind of pretty candy thing. I guess it's nice that people like it I like his attitude about that. I know in general I was just like I was very impressed with Joe's attitude about this whole thing
它通常被描述为一堵墙，我不认为人们知道它是一个经济型工作空间，这是奥运会遗产可能带来的一个试点项目。它可以被部署来让艺术家们继续在城市里工作。我觉得所有这些东西都丢失了，真是一种遗憾。它最终只变成了这种漂亮的美化糖果。我想人们喜欢它还是挺不错的。我喜欢他对此的态度。我一般知道，我只是对乔对待整件事的态度印象深刻……
towards the end of our interview Joe just kind of in the studio in London like I could tell he had pulled out his phone and was scrolling through and looking at some of these pictures. And it's interesting because people, you know, the way Instagram works like a lot of old things will get kind of resurfaced and reposted. So even though the wall in London doesn't is not up anywhere, but the photos of it still kind of tend to resurface on Instagram as if it still was. Right. Um, so as we're scrolling through, he was, you know, coming across all these different photos. Yeah, they're still posting about it, aren't they? Mad, completely mad. There's a wedding here.
在采访快结束时，乔在伦敦的工作室里，我能看出他拿出了手机，在翻看并浏览其中的一些照片。这很有趣，因为人们，你知道，Instagram的工作方式就像许多旧事物会以某种方式重新浮出水面并被重新发布一样。因此，尽管伦敦的那堵墙已经不在任何地方了，但它的照片仍然往往会重新出现在Instagram上，就好像它还在一样。对吧。嗯，所以当我们浏览时，他遇到了所有这些不同的照片。是的，他们还在发关于它的帖子，不是吗？太疯狂了，完全疯狂。这里有一场婚礼。
Look at that. Unbelievable. It's a beautiful thing. It's a beautiful thing to see. It brings back memories. Oh memories. And you know most of these photos are kind of what we describe in the piece. It's like either someone standing in front of the wall or jumping or holding a dog or
看那个。难以置信。这是一件美好的事情。看到这一幕是一件美好的事情。它唤起了回忆。哦，回忆。你知道，这些照片大部分都是我们在报道中描述的那种。要么是有人站在墙前面，要么是在跳跃，或者抱着狗，或者
the baby or just a lot of shots of the wall itself. But as Joe was scrolling through, we came across one that was kind of special. See, look, there it is on a bed sheet. Oh my God, look, that's so cool. So that is the coolest one yet. You've got a feature that this blanket was inspired by the much photographed Tiled Wall at Sugar House Studios. Someone made a quilt of it.
抱着婴儿，或者只是很多墙壁本身的特写镜头。但正当乔在浏览时，我们偶然发现了一张有点特别的照片。看，看，它在一张床单上。哦天哪，看，太酷了。所以这是迄今为止最酷的一张。你必须指出这条毛毯的灵感来自于糖屋工作室那面被疯狂拍照的瓷砖墙。有人用它做了一件被子。
So it's not that it's a print. Someone's actually bought different fabrics and kind of crocheted them together. And what I love, I mean, I just love, you can tell it's just like a little bit enchanted by this. Yeah, totally. It's not the best merch that we would ever be able to make. That's so cool. What is it? Could you show me a picture of it? Yeah, here. Take a look. Oh, it's so cool. What is it? Could you show me a picture of it?
所以这不是印花。有人真的买了不同的面料并将它们钩针编织在一起。我最喜欢的，我的意思是，我只是喜欢，你可以看出他对这个有点着迷。对，完全是这样。这不是我们能做出的最好的周边。太酷了。这是什么？你能给我看看它的照片吗？对，在这里。看一看。哦，太酷了。这是什么？你能给我看看它的照片吗？
Yeah, here. Take a look. Oh, it's really nice. It's not really a quilt. It's like a crochet blanket. Yeah, I think it's more like a throw blanket on top of your bed. But it's really beautiful. And you can just tell how much work went into making this. Totally. So who made this? So this is someone named Jillian Row
对，在这里。看一看。哦，真的很好。这其实不是一床被子。它更像是一条钩针编织的毯子。对，我觉得它更像是铺在床上的那种盖毯。但它真的很美。你能看出制作这个投入了多少心血。完全是这样。那这是谁做的呢？这个人叫吉莉安·罗（Jillian Row），
who has the Instagram handle, Tails from a happy house. Tails from a happy house. She's based in Hampshire and it looks like she finished the quilt in September this year. Maybe we'll message her and say that it looks fantastic. In September this year, maybe we'll message her.
她的Instagram账号是“快乐之家的尾巴”（Tails from a happy house）。“快乐之家的尾巴”。她住在汉普郡，看起来她在今年9月份完成了这件被子。也许我们会给她发信息说它看起来棒极了。今年9月份，也许我们会给她发信息。
And say that it looks fantastic. So I'm not sure if you'll message her, but I did. Oh, that's good. So I DMed her on Instagram and she agreed to chat on the phone. And I called her up. I didn't have a whole lot of questions, but I just wanted to let her know that the people who designed the wall really thought her blanket was really cool. I was talking with one of the designers of the wall and we were scrolling through Instagram. The reason that I found you is that we were scrolling through Instagram together.
并说它看起来棒极了。所以我不太确定你是否会给她发信息，但我发了。哦，那太好了。所以我通过Instagram私信了她，她同意在电话里聊聊。我没有太多问题，但我只是想让她知道，设计那堵墙的人真的认为她的毯子太酷了。我当时正在和墙壁的一位设计者交谈，我们在刷Instagram。我找到你的原因是我们一起在刷Instagram。
We came across your blanket and he was genuinely moved by how beautiful your blanket was. Oh, that's so nice. Oh, I's so nice. Oh, I really tried to tell me that. That's lovely. Yeah. Oh, that's sweet. Oh, I love that.
我们偶然看到了你的毯子，他对你的毯子是多么美丽感到由衷的感动。哦，太好了。哦，太好了。哦，真的很努力地告诉我这些。太可爱了。对。哦，太甜了。哦，我太喜欢了。
Yeah, she just seems like a really sweet person. And one thing that I figured out and talking to her was that she had never actually visited the wall. Like her experience of this wall was entirely. So that's a really good screen. Oh, it was only on Instagram. Yeah, no, I've never been there. I'd like to go but I spend time as limited and if I was going to face London for today, there are probably if I'm really honest, other things I'd probably go there to meet a friend or maybe have a day out with my family and if I'm going with my family then I'm not dragging them all to a wall. I'm gonna to go to the Natural History Museum or something, aren't we?
对，她看起来真的是个很甜美的人。在与她交谈后我发现的一件事是，她其实从未去过那堵墙。也就是说她对这堵墙的体验完全是……所以那是一个很好的屏幕。哦，那只是在Instagram上。对，不，我从来没去过。我很想去，但我的时间有限，如果我要去伦敦待一天说实话，如果有的话，我可能会做别的事，比如去见个朋友，或者和家人一起度过一天，如果我和家人一起去，我就不会把他们全拖到一面墙前。我们会去自然历史博物馆什么的，对吧？
That makes sense. I mean, this one thing is kind of amazing about this. I mean, you could view this, the de-contextualization of the imagery of a piece of architecture in lots of different ways. And I think you could have a kind of a cynical view of it that, like, you know, erasing the meaning of a wall or a building has some negative side effects. But in this case, and probably lots of cases, I mean, this is a pattern that people experienced just through Instagram and gave them joy.
这说得通。我的意思是，关于这一点，有一件事可以说是相当奇妙的。我的意思是，你可以从很多不同的角度来看待这种建筑艺术影像的去语境化。我想你可能会对它抱有一种愤世嫉俗的看法，比如，抹去一面墙或一座建筑的意义会带来一些负面的副作用。但在这种情况下，可能在很多情况下，我的意思是，这只是一种人们通过Instagram体验到并带给他们快乐的模式。
And in this case, you know, another piece of beautiful art was created. And so, you know, it's not like this is negative. This is just what it is. Yeah, and that was like, I think that was like the entire experience of reporting this piece was kind of like being like, is this bad? Is this good?
在这种情况下，你知道，另一件美丽的艺术品诞生了。所以，你知道，这并非什么负面影响。它就是这样。是的，这就是——我想整个报道这篇稿件的过程大概就是这样，一直在想：这不好吗？这好吗？
Is this dystopian? Is it a utopia? You know, like I just like kind of kept going back and forth on that and, you know, in the end, I think it's just like a mixed bag. It's like, there are, there are weird, it's just weird, like's just living in the internet age and trying to interact in the digital and physical world at the same time is just a weird messy thing.
这是反乌托邦吗？这是乌托邦吗？你知道，我就是一直在两者之间摇摆不定，你知道，最后，我觉得这其实是个复杂的混合体。就像是，有，有一些奇怪的，这真的很奇怪，生活在互联网时代，试图同时在数字世界和物理世界中互动，本来就是一件奇怪且混乱的事情。
But yeah, I think that this example was for me, a really nice one, whereas here's someone that found something online and made something real in the world out of it. She didn't even have a relationship at the physical place. And Joe and the assemble team could feel mixed about some of the uses, but there's really truly nothing more amazing than being an artist who makes art to inspire other artists to create beautiful things. Totally.
不过是的，我觉得这个例子对我来说是一个非常棒的例子，这里有人在网上发现了某个东西，并以此在现实世界中创造出了真实的东西。她甚至与那个实体地点没有任何联系。虽然乔和Assemble团队对其中一些用途可能会有复杂的感受，但作为一个艺术家，创作艺术来启发其他艺术家创造美好的事物，真的没有比这更奇妙的事情了。完全同意。
That's the greatest gift in the world. Right, totally. I think that there's nothing negative you could think about this blanket. That's so good. Well, thanks for this little adendum to the story. That's awesome. Yeah, absolutely. Thank you.
那是世界上最好的礼物。对，完全同意。我觉得关于这条毯子，你不可能产生任何负面的想法。太棒了。好吧，谢谢你为这个故事补充的这段小插曲。太棒了。是的，绝对的。谢谢你。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, Mix and Tech Production by Shereef Yusuf, Music by Sean Raal. Katie Mingle is our senior producer Kurt Colstad is the digital director, the rest of the team is senior editor Delaney Hall, Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Barouba, Sophia Klatsker, and me, Roman Mars. A stuut listener will notice that for the first time in nearly seven years, Avery Trophiman is missing from this list. If you didn't catch the announcement at the end of her brilliant Articles of Interest series, you should go listen to it, but just know that she is moving on to do some new things, and I'm confident that those projects will be as inspiring and beautiful
本周的《99% Invisible》由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）制作，混音与技术制作由谢里夫·优素福（Shereef Yusuf）负责，音乐由肖恩·拉尔（Sean Raal）创作。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是我们的资深制作人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Colstad）是数字总监，团队的其他成员包括资深编辑德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、薇薇安·勒（Vivian Le）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、克里斯·巴鲁巴（Chris Barouba）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。细心的听众会发现，近七年来，艾弗里·特罗菲曼（Avery Truffiman）的名字第一次从这个名单中消失了。如果你没有听到她那部精彩的《兴趣文章》（Articles of Interest）系列节目末尾的公告，你应该去听一下，但只要知道她将去开展一些新的工作，我相信这些项目将会和她在NINI-PI（99pi）的所有作品一样鼓舞人心、美丽动人，
and as interesting as all her work has been here at NINI-PI. She brought so much to the show and shaped who we are today in inculcable ways. I know you will miss hearing her stories on the air and just know that we're gonna miss her a thousand times more. Godspeed, Aves. In regard to this episode, special thanks to Diana Buds from Curved and Cooper Rogers. We have a handful of thank yous from the thousands of people who support radiootopia, including Paul Thomas, Ellie Paul, Selena Dixon, Dio Augustus Prime, and Corina Mikutska. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is now distributed in multiple
并且同样有趣。她为这个节目贡献了太多，并以无法估量的方式塑造了今天的我们。我知道你们会想念在空中听到她的故事，只需知道我们会以千倍的思念来怀念她。一路顺风，Aves。关于本集节目，特别感谢来自Curved的黛安娜·巴兹（Diana Buds）和库珀·罗杰斯（Cooper Rogers）。我们还要感谢成千上万支持Radiotopia的听众中的几位，包括保罗·托马斯（Paul Thomas）、埃莉·保罗（Ellie Paul）、塞雷娜·迪克森（Selena Dixon）、迪奥·奥古斯都·普赖姆（Dio Augustus Prime）和科里娜·米库茨卡（Corina Mikutska）。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的项目，制作于Radio Row，现在它已经分布在东湾的多个地点，但在我们的心中，它永远都在。
locations around the East Bay, but in our hearts, it will always be. In beautiful. Downtown. Oakland, California. We are a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative, listener-supported podcasts in the world. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 9.9.pi.org,
美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是PRX旗下Radiotopia的自豪成员，这是一个由全球最具创新性、听众支持的播客组成的充满独立精神的集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 上寻找它们。你可以在推特上@Roman Mars，或在节目账号 9.9.pi.org 上找到我们，
or on Instagram and read it too. But if you want old fashioned words to go with your pictures, we got it all at 9.9.pi.org. Radio Tepio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者在Instagram和Reddit上也行。但如果你想要配图的老式文字，我们在 9.9.pi.org 上应有尽有。来自PRX的Radiotopia。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。